foreign
[Music]
this is talk TV
I am Rosanna Lockwood uncensored tonight
with insiders claiming Harry and Megan
will stop publicly criticizing the royal
family because they've got nothing left
to say we ask is this an olive branch
that could finally end the Windsor Civil
War or is it just another push for
publicity the UK government are taking
the covert inquiry to court so what's
really happening to boris's WhatsApp
messages Isabel oakshaw Richard Tyson
Davis and Tina join me to talk Politics
as a standoff continues and with Eco
protesters all set to disrupt another
big horse race this weekend I'll be
asking a former jockey a racing
specialist and a member of the Eco mob
if they're pushing the British public to
Breaking Point
[Music]
live from the news building in London
this is Piers Morgan uncensored with
Rosanna Lockwood well that Sprint never
gets any shorter does it happy Thursday
welcome to Pierce Morgan uncensored me
Rosanna Lockwood sitting in the chair
for the big man at once again for a
final time for this week
and with a topic dear to his heart Harry
and Megan the never-ending soap opera
that some people cannot get enough of
and some people would rather see and
hear less of but I suppose that's really
the point isn't it even if you're fed up
with it they're just always there this
ceaseless circular Feast between the
couple and the media they say they hate
when they're in charge it's the sit down
confessionals with Oprah the unsparing
tell-all Memoirs and the reported 100
million dollar multi Netflix contract
but now we're supposedly going to hear
something different from them let's take
a listen
got that
sorry the paddle are laughing it's The
Sound of Silence we'll come to the panel
shortly yes it is The Sound of Silence
according to new reports Harry and Megan
have apparently decided to stop
criticizing the royal family in books or
on TV because there's just nothing left
to say so is this a sign that this sort
of real life Game of Thrones between the
house of Sussex and the house of Windsor
is finally over is it Checkmate to the
king and the King to be or are these
planes just part of a wider PR strategy
let's remember what the South Park
creators made of all this
why
[Music]
because because
now of course not everyone believes
Harry and Megan will or ever can stay Mr
Pierce Morgan himself sharing his views
on Twitter today on the sausage staying
silent you got the reference there I'm
sure you did I didn't explain that one
me personally I suppose a bit of Silence
would be nice I mean I'm ever The
Optimist I do like to see people fulfill
their dreams and if that means at last a
classy Quiet Retreat from public
spectacle and an end to the repeated
attempted dismemberment in the British
Monarchy then sure see yourselves out
enjoy life in California shut the door
quietly
but I do have a suspicion that peers
might win this bet here to discuss what
all of this means I'm joined in the
studio by Richard fitzwilliams public
relations consultant and World
commentator and talktv contributor Paula
Roan Adrian always great to see you both
and going to Mike Paul first president
and CEO of reputation Dr down the line
joining us from the US this evening Mike
we'll we'll start we'll start with you
is it is it where you sold on this these
reported sources saying that Harry and
Megan are kind of done with being out
there
oh whenever you say you're done for life
I always have a warning for any client
that's in that kind of a situation but I
think we need to remember the two pieces
that really tie to why they were upset
in the first place and it was tied to
remarks about their children and remarks
that were filled with race really racism
if those two issues are off the table
dealing with the Royals historically
that's not how it's gone
then I think they have an opportunity
but I think we need to look for the
future to still have those two issues
discussions of the children that might
not be something that they accept
especially from a race perspective and
of course Harry marrying a woman who is
biracial and race always being a part of
the issue I think you raise an
interesting point that is worth
remembering where this all comes from of
course from Harry's point of view as
well he always brings up obviously his
upbringing what happened to his mother
those are the reasons he uses uh you
know in his long-running battles with
the press and with the media as well I
want to come to Paula in the studio to
react to some of what you said that
might do you think that's fair Paula
that you know that is what will keep the
discussion going um the children and the
race issues and of course the press and
the press's reaction because let's not
forget that when we have a story like
Megan and Harry it's the press and their
ability to manipulate that story
manipulate the narrative I think that's
what's going to be pushing this so for
example you spoke about in your
introduction about the Privacy we saw
the South Park clip about privacy
nowhere in Harry's speech when he
finally said afraid we've got to go guys
nowhere did he say in that speech I am
going I'm leaving the royal family I'm
leaving this country to lead a private
life that's not what they said in fact
they said the absolute opposite they
said they wanted to continue their
charitable work they said they wanted to
continue the Royal Legacy because they
weren't able to do that and we also have
to remember that this is a family this
is a man who lost his mother and wanted
to protect his wife a wife who has
received death threats real death
threats people are in prison now serving
sentences for those death threats of
course he wanted to and needed to speak
out so Richard let's come to you on this
because that is what Paul is pointing
out it's a battle between the media and
the sussexes here and what is the
ultimate resolution and often the
complaint that you hear contrary to what
Paul is saying is that they have
demanded that they be left alone and yet
they still keep putting themselves out
there well firstly the idea of the
silent sussexes it's an interesting
concept but I certainly don't entertain
much hope that we are going to get it
because there are several issues
involved here now the first one
regarding spare which I have to say I
wondered who'd advised Harry the issues
such as how he lost his virginity the
drugs issue which is going to be raised
in court in the United States as to how
he entered and so forth and then of
course a penile frostbite that sort of
thing I mean I wondered saying how many
people and how many Afghans he'd taken
out that was extremely ill advice he
wondered who was advising him but on
this particular issue what we're seeing
is very much someone who's I think a
campaigner now he believes that with
regard to the press as you were saying I
mean it is something that he feels very
deeply about he actually believes it's
his life's work he's called it to clear
up the cleanup the what he sees is the
origin Stables of the British media
there are several court cases no less
than five three of them against to Media
groups either about to start or having
started and what we've seen is I think a
very very
bitter Harry but on the other hand don't
forget the contract with random house
because here's another danger of the
royal family for one second think that
they sussexes are necessarily implicated
because they haven't received the
apology they hoped for
it was a four book deal we've been told
with random house Megan could write a
Memoirs Harry could have a book out of
the 800 Pages we only had 400 in Spain
he could write about his childhood so we
have a lot to play for so to speak yes
about the Sussex is in the international
Arena concerned look coming back to Mike
um what you're thinking when you're
hearing all of this I mean so far we
haven't had I think any extreme views
which you sometimes get in debates about
sussexes are sort of just everyone just
wants them to shut the hell up
um we're hearing pretty balanced remarks
here about the press and the
relationship with them
well I think it's important to
understand some key terms like leaks
that's what those cases are about so
let's be accurate about why Harry is so
upset and he wants the world to
understand quite frankly how the
tabloids work in the UK with a lot of
leaks even from family members releasing
some of those leads and that was also in
the book the comments that recently came
out about having a different View and
saying we're done with it was really
about attacks that dealt with race
children and various crisis issues that
were tied to the sepsis not everything
so let's not throw the baby in with the
bath water and say that they're not
going to speak at all they're never
going to come out of the house of course
that's not what we're talking about and
yes there are different kinds of books
that can be written and they can also
produce things for Netflix and not only
be the stars of it in defending but I
would say this
I don't think Henry and Megan are ever
going to give up the opportunity and the
responsibility to defend themselves and
their children if they have personally
attacked with lives I don't think that
is ever going to end I'm like they're
perfectly entitled to do that as you
said and they are private individuals
and they have a certain amount of
celebrity brand of course I want to ask
you from your reputation specialism
point of view do you think it's been a
successful Rebrand for the two of them
in the US and here in the UK
to date no and the reason why is the
root of their brand especially calories
that trips into Megan's and to the
children is at its core right
not American
not a reality star not a defender of
various things that he's even gone
through in life if you're brand at its
core is one and you take that away
your brand is damaged what you need to
do is leave open the opportunity of
potentially like someone have said in
the media most recently that you might
rejoin the royal family in phones that
you might still move back to the UK that
you might still have a Mia culpa that
earns your way back into the royal
family in a very different way quite
frankly the way that the king had hoped
that it would be
original Mike uh gonna come to the
voices in the studio because you've got
two uh people here in Britain shaking
their head vigorously to some of the
things you're saying and I think it's to
do with Paula Harry coming back to the
UK and his relationship with the Royals
I did want to slightly disagree with
Mike on this one because remember we had
the people's princess yeah Diana took a
very bold move and she left and she not
only left the royal family she left this
country and we were told that that was
absolutely her plan was to to to live
away from this country and in effect
it's sad to see that Harry has had to
say take that same path in order to do
what he thinks he needs to do to protect
his wife and coming back to this issue
this relationship with the Press
ultimately it I was intrigued at the way
the story was being sold today oh he's
finally going to stop talking oh he's
finally going to shush oh he's finally
not going to say anything the Press
aren't going to leave him alone the
Press aren't going to leave her alone
and anytime they dare to open their
mouths about anything thing she
straightened her hair Rosanna yeah and
it and it made front headlights of
course it's important business
apparently it is
so important in the enormity of the
brand it's very interesting because when
one's thinking of how well they're doing
the extremely controversial near
catastrophic car chase which I think
much of a horrible experience there's
absolutely no doubt and there's no doubt
it brought memories of Diana back I mean
the paparazzi in my viewer lower Richard
you agreed that it was near catastrophic
because there were no one necessarily
there some Recollections may vary on
that point yeah but indeed none of us
were there but near catch a story was
the wording they used and it was
debunked a little bit certainly hasn't
been yeah tough as the exact title but
what what interests me is the positively
frenetic media interest worldwide in
them and there's absolutely no doubt us
Harry goes through these various court
case is we also as I said we could see
further books as far as Netflix
concerned we saw a six-hour document
series which I don't think was
particularly helpful although it wasn't
desperately harmful but spare was uh him
going spare as I saw it and those
interviews as well all so many were so
damaging to them let me ask you from a
subjective point of view Richard because
you've watched the world for most of
your career do you want to see Harry go
silent and disappear would you think
that would be better for him I don't
think that he and Megan have any
intention of doing that but I want to
see what I want to see is them ceasing
to attack the royal family because what
we've had is a form of Guerrilla War
over a period of time since they stepped
down and it began without and
subsequently of course we've seen a lot
of it recently but the thing is the
palace can't fight back not easily at
the moment they fight back sources say
sources say sources say and the palace
fight and they fight hard the palace
can't make statements and if they can't
make States there's always the problem
is the is then can control the agenda
and that is what they're superb in doing
and that is what I fear it's got this
Rift here it's going to go on I wish it
had never happened believe me of course
yeah you know there are subjective
points on this there are the facts and
there is everything else and there is a
reputation of brand issue we've been
very pleased to be joined by Mike Paul
in the US this evening on this as well
as Paula Richard here in the studio
thank you so much for joining us for
this talk now uncensored next tonight
where are boris's whatsapps the
government have them that will the
public or the covered inquiry ever get
to see them or at least the ones from
pre-2021 we'll get to the bottom of that
next
[Music]
president first lady thank you both very
much indeed prime minister thank you
[Music]
very much
time
say something because I like it as
simple as that I don't say that in
public
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
sitting in the chair for Fears tonight
now the government is going to take this
coveted inquiry to court Yes you heard
me right over its demand for Boris
Johnson's WhatsApp messages and
documents this is during the time of the
covid pandemic now officials were given
until 4pm this afternoon to hand over
all that information passed to them by
the former prime minister so supposedly
Boris handed over what he had to the
government officials they were going to
hand over to the inquiry we're waiting
until 4pm to see if that happened welds
a few gaps in this let us tell you that
the government has refused to disclose
certain elements of the material to the
inquiry and even Boris Johnson himself
suggested he was willing to hand over
the messages himself but there's still
some disclaimers in that as well let's
go into this with our pack it's a
complicated story but I promise you it's
interesting here in the studio where
this is reform UK leader and talk TV
present Richard Tice talk to his
International editor Isabel oakshott the
woman behind of course the lockdown file
is quite the person to speak to on this
and political journalist Ava Santina as
well also a good voice on this uh you
all are there's no preference here but I
do have a preference for Isabel today
I'm afraid because Isabel let's remind
our viewers uh did some reporting in
which she released Matt Hancock's uh
messages from the time of the pandemic
it's called the WhatsApp files many of
us were actually with Boris Johnson and
Boris Johnson and it is in various
WhatsApp groups that I obtained from
Matt Hancock so I've actually seen a lot
of Boris Johnson's WhatsApp messages I
am astonished that the government has
taken this step you said it's
complicated and in a way it is and in a
way it's quite simple the simple version
is the government does not want the
covert inquiry to be very revelatory I
think we know this because there's no
deadline on the inquiry they basically
just want it to go away so the last
thing they want is the judge in the code
inquiry seeing all the secret messages
that went between the Prime Minister and
other ministers during the pandemic
that's how many many decisions were made
they were made via WhatsApp so the
government is trying to keep that quiet
the complication here is that this is a
government appointing a new judge to try
to stop the judge they the government
appointed to conduct the covert inquiry
from doing the job they asked her to do
try and get your head around that indeed
and it seems like it was a very
dangerous precedent Richard it's
unbelievable yeah the government is
suing the own judge that the government
appointed you couldn't make it up this
is a complete abuse of power by this
government it doesn't want the Truth
Exposed the reality is the inquiry would
be better just to look at all the
WhatsApp messages nothing else from the
key players and nothing else it could do
that frankly by the end of this year and
that would tell us the lessons we need
to know it's doing exactly the opposite
I think the challenge is on some of the
former cabinet ministers who are
involved at the time they should
actually take it into their own hands
and give the messages
I think a few of them have said that
that is the right thing to do I don't
think the government's position is going
to hold I you must be a little a Teensy
bit impressed that Boris Johnson has
volunteered his messages I don't I I
would be if I actually believe that he'd
handed over everything I mean I think
there's like a large part of me that
thinks that he's possibly you know
obligated a few or he might get to keep
himself
questioning is honesty well there may be
a lot was done on telegram or another
platform which is not right over and
there to think of this is of course the
taxpayer will be footing the bill for a
lot of what is going this for all that's
going on and I'm feeling like this
entire conversation is entirely
one-sided but who could be in the camp
of the government right now that is
doing this and then the general public
watching this and thinking hang on a
minute just give over the evidence but
it was a confusing time I mean I kind of
feel sorry for Greg hands because he is
the minister who get what the ex
Minister who keeps putting out the the
same message from the labor government
from the last Labor government which was
there's no money left I mean by the time
we finish with this inquiry there's
going to be no money there isn't any
already you know I think exactly but you
know the big point I think that we
really can't be stressed enough is that
Richie sunac when he took the position
he said he promised accountability and
integrity and I think everyone in the
country can look at this and say there
is none of that present at the moment so
he's looking up off that Richard yeah
picking up of that what do we think
people are worried about coming out and
we'll come to you is about as well
because you've probably seen uh on the
other half of those messages that you've
seen what people are worried about the
assumption is that it's people worried
about their jobs worried about things
they said about other people gossip
Westminster stuff but could it be worse
no I think it's far worse I think what
they're worried about is February and
March 2020. that's the period when
critical decisions were taken and
actually I think they're worried about
the truth is they weren't following the
best scientific advice I think they were
making decisions on the hoof uh catching
up belatedly and they were worried about
how does it look how does it affect my
political career that's what they'll be
worried about and you know my view on
this is you know I was in another part
of the world during the pandemic I saw
the way other governments reacted to
this and all governments everywhere were
panicking and floundering and trying to
make best sense of the science of the
time so I maybe have give a bit more
allowance but the public do still care
about this Isabelle as a a survey 44 of
those are so partygate matters as much
now as it did when Boris Johnson was
prime minister and some 26 said it
matters more so the public do read well
we should all still care about what
happened during lockdown because ever
every single person in this country is
still paying a price I mean many people
tragically paid with their lives as a
result of the government's policies
whether that is unnecessary covert
deaths linked to how Care Homes were
managed or is it unnecessary excess
deaths that we're now seeing at this
point because of the collapse in things
like routine Cancer Care so everybody
should care about what happened during
the pandemic and the lessons to be
learned you asked what is it that they
are worried about put very simply what
they're worried about is what what is
within those messages
conflicting with what they were telling
us publicly that's the dynamite here
where they were telling us one thing
publicly and privately there was a
different narrative that is incredibly
problematic the gossip the kind of
off-color remarks the you know the
personality stuff the judge will weed
that out she will not consider a lot of
that to be remotely irrelevant to the
inquiry so for the cabinet office to
argue that she shouldn't have access to
the entire cash because some of it's
irrelevant is really lame which is more
than capable of picking the wheat from
the sifting the wheat from the chaff the
judge might be but the Press Ava won't
if they get any kind of hint of this any
of the gossip and the and the sort of
headline making stuff you know
potentially politicians making jibes at
each other and WhatsApp messages or
stitching each other up can you see this
rolling on for a long time I mean look
at what came out of the Matt Hancock
files right and it was absolutely
extraordinary and you know on your point
about the sort of the fallacies and what
Matt Hancock showed himself to do and
there's WhatsApp was to be trying to
communicate for his own gain like a lot
of the policies that were being put
forward he was trying to make himself
look good rather than actually doing the
best for the country and look look Boris
Johnson has handed over it you know
supposedly all of his whatsapps that
must mean that other cabinet ministers
who are currently in post look really
stupid otherwise he wouldn't do it in
the first place there's always an
ulterior motive with him and also
supposedly not the phone from pre what
was it March May 2021 he has quite good
reason for not having just to hand it
over that phone initially I was like oh
here it goes this is the you know it's
all falling apart it's not as it seemed
with Boris but in fact he had been told
he claims Anyway by the security
services that that phone had become a
major risk and a vulnerability I'm
guessing that in some way that it was
bugged that was the fear he hasn't been
allowed even to turn it on so he has
said that he is very happy to hand over
that phone as long as it's dealt with by
the security services
look going on while we've got this
powerful political panel here we must
move on to this story that has just
dropped we're going to show you a video
now this is US President Biden handing
out a diploma at the U.S Air Force
Academy
oh
now that is a deeply unfortunate tumble
isn't it and if it was any other world
leader we might sort of have a little
laugh a bit cruelly perhaps but we would
say you know that is just unfortunately
he's fooled off fell off a step there it
could happen to anyone but this is Biden
he has form he has history of falling
over it's stumbling and this is quite
full it's going to be a hard one to come
back from image wise I think especially
Richard when always so many questions
around his age and whether he's fit to
serve another term but it's not the
first time is it he's stumbling up steps
down steps he turns one way when he
should have turned the other way this
man is not phys he's just not fit to be
president of you know the Free World
frankly and the idea that he could be on
the ballot paper in November 2014 I
think is for the birds and I think
because this I mean it's a tragic scene
to watch an old man could fall over too
though yeah but but an old man
he keeps doing it this is this is an old
man who is continually uh showing
himself to not be fit to be president
he's a man in his 80s most people in
their 80s if they fall over like that he
fell hard he will have really really
hurt himself potentially injured himself
uh quite seriously and I just think
those around him are they doing the
right thing by encouraging him to carry
on well Ava is there an argument for we
just need a president's brain do they
need to be stuck
unfortunately
I mean you could do a bit of you know
good PR there couldn't you you could you
might look at that if you're as advisors
and say maybe he shouldn't be out in the
sun for a few hours handing out you know
Awards maybe he should just be kept away
just some positive PR maybe not let
Putin see how difficult he found it
getting back up again oh gosh every time
you show it it's making me crying yeah
he gets up quite quick argument for
upper age limit on uh world leaders then
or should it be Fitness assess Richard
it's Fitness assessed and he's clearly
not fit there's all sorts of concerns
about his cognitive of ability and this
is just reinforced it it's not the first
time they've just got to be honest with
with their own people and frankly with
the world I'd be interested
unfortunately we don't have an American
sat in the studio with us this evening
but we will perhaps uh destroy pull them
and see how they feel about that because
I think even the Democrats it's a tough
watch obviously yeah absolutely yeah
look there's so much to discuss but
we're really pleased to have you in this
evening to discuss all of those WhatsApp
messages we'll have to see how that all
pans out uncensored next tonight do Eco
Warriors do more harm than good with
dangerous stunts at Big public events
are they finally pushing the public to
the brink of apathy and despair we'll be
debating that next
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the show uncensored with
me Rosanna in the chair tonight Eco
groups have been targeting sporting
events for months now from animal Rising
attempting to storm the Grand National
Aintree to just stop oil staging a stunt
you might remember this one during the
World Snooker Championship Playoffs
table there and pouring orange powder
all over himself that one really caught
the headlines didn't it today delaying
England's return to test Cricket action
by blocking the team bus on route to
Lords and another big horse racing event
this weekend in Peril meanwhile the
government is gearing up to make changes
to the law to crack down on these
disruptive protests now is that okay in
your eyes or should the government just
be letting them get on with it with me
to discuss all of this animal Rising
activist Orla Cochran in the studio
thanks for joining us once again on this
show and the horse racing journalist
down the line from Epsom where the Derby
is happening this weekend under threat
Kevin Blake good to see you as well sir
now let's get into this and uh talk to
you Kevin given that you are down there
in Epsom already and find out a little
bit about what is planned for this
weekend and your concerns
well look it's been well publicized
Rosanna that um this group animal Rising
have been very public in saying that
they intend to disrupt the Derby they
intend to hold
um if you will a peaceful protest
outside the track but also attempt to
infiltrate the track and disrupt the
race
um such as the level of threat to and
the safety of all involved and the race
itself that the Jockey Club have
successfully taken out an injunction and
in an effort to stop these protests
getting
um you know crossing the line from
peaceful to law breaking and and that's
where we stand at the minute I think
it's a cloud hanging over this great
race that has taken place since 1780 you
know through two world wars wasn't
enough to stop but they moved it to New
Market and covert wasn't enough to stop
us but had the threat of these protests
are really worrying everyone not just
for the race but for the horses and all
the people involved as well yeah I've
spoke to somebody already today who's
withdrawn a horse from the race this
weekend over those concerns it is very
real the concerns and we spoke to in the
lead up to the Grand National and we
talked about some of the things and
obviously we saw a lot happen from that
and some 120 uh protesters were of
course I think detained uh from that
event in Aintree let's come to all that
now here in the studio from animal rise
in the group and ask why why are you
objecting so much to this race
uh first of all thank you so much for
having me on the show
um so we're doing this for two main
reasons um the first one is that we
really care about animals and we care
very much about these horses and so
we're trying to protect them from harm
and the second reason is that we are
trying to have a bigger conversation
about the way that we're treating
animals I believe that most good people
care about animals but I don't believe
that our actions as a society are in
line with those values and so I'm trying
to have
um a big public conversation about the
way that we're treating horses
specifically because we know that a
horse dies every other day in British
racing let's come back to Kevin then on
this because uh Kevin you highlighted an
interesting uh Point earlier when we
spoke which is that animal Rising uh
there seems to be a bit of a conflict
here and I'll allow orlo to join this
conversation as well on what the whole
objection to this race is because other
members of the group animal Rising Orla
have said that they I can understand
that the horse racing industry loves
horses and yet at the same time you say
say you can't love horses and race them
so Kevin what has it meant to you to
have these kind of lines of messaging
how do you combat it
just to expand on that quote that was
from Nathan McGovern
um in the the racing post today Rosanna
it's important to repeat that because he
said in his own words for us it's not a
it's not an animal welfare issue it's
not specifically anti-horse racing we
have been very public in saying that
there is an intention to cause the Derby
to be delayed or canceled with the
ultimate goal being to bring the
spotlight and what we would call our
broken relationship with animals in the
natural world so that that tells you
exactly what a lot of us have thought
Rosanna that we've seen through this
it's been very transparent from the
outset that you know this group's actual
real understanding of the Thoroughbred
and horse racing is minimal you know
they're ultimately using horse racing as
a trojan horse if you will you know for
them this is about high-profile
publicity stunts to get their name out
there and to try and attract donations
to what is a much wider much more
extreme world view than a simple
opposition to horse racing and Orla in
her second point there you know
essentially confirm that they want to
have a wider discussion about our broken
relationship with animals so like I
think it's important that we do that
Rosanna and there's been some mixed
messages in recent days so I'd like to
ask order very directly because I think
it's very important that the British
public know what this group represents
what their opinions are you know I would
like to hear more about what animal
rising's position is and people owning
domesticated animals go on all that
because I too get a little bit confused
about this you know in our lead in there
we're talking about Eco groups and
you're not a climate change activism
group but do you want veganism do you
want everyone to stop riding horses do
you want people to stop owning pets I
mean you need the British public to
understand exactly what you're getting
at if you want your message to get
across and as Kevin's saying that you're
using horse racing just as a pawn in
this
well I would completely disagree that
we're using horse racing horse racing is
a horse racing is a part of this problem
we know that Horus dies as I said every
other day in British racing and so what
we're trying to do is ask the general
public if this is in line with our
values as a nation of animal lovers
and Kevin you haven't answered the
question there you haven't answered the
direct question there or I think but the
a lot of the viewers will might be quite
ambivalent about horse racing but
domesticated animals are very important
to the nation of animal lovers you know
what's animal risings policy there do
they believe that people should be
allowed have own domesticated animals
is this like cats and dogs you're
referring to yes absolutely yeah
so we know there's a huge problem as
well in the UK with with animal breeding
I do think this has gone slightly off
topic um but we know I disagree actually
although I think this is very on topic
because you began the discussion by
talking about domesticated animals the
relationship with animals and as one of
your other spokespeople has pointed out
they understand that horse racing
industry actually does really love
horses so it's confusing we just want to
get to the bottom of it yeah I
completely understand that I guess my
point is that a majority of deaths are
happening on the racetrack in the public
eye and we also know that a billion
animals are killed in the food system so
that's why we're focusing on the biggest
issues obviously we also have an issue
with overbreeding uh pets we also have
an issue with things like poppy farms
and so we would always encourage people
and to adopt rather than shopping
um for pets because we believe that pets
can can be part of a family
um as opposed to you know being owned
okay and with horses the ultimate goal
here as far as the research I've seen
into what you want is rewilding of
horses and you understand of course that
there are red horses bred for racing uh
unsuitable to be just let back out into
the wild so again the statement from the
another member of the organization today
was that we'll just be okay if
thoroughbred horses go extinct as a
result of that
well not at all I think what we can do
is we can bring the horses that we have
already bred into our retirement so they
can live out a long happy life and we
know that a majority
um of horse races in this industry don't
have that that long happy life and so
that's really what we're asking for
um to give these horses the life that
they deserve Uh Kevin yeah
how is that practical how where are you
going to put these horses you know
you're talking about tens and tens of
thousands of horses that currently have
a very specific purpose and you want to
bring that direct purpose that that
purpose to an end you know how is that
in any way practical you know one of
your colleagues suggested putting them
in sanctuaries you know I think there's
only like literally a few dozen
sanctuaries in the UK that are capable
of taking horses you know you'd have to
fit two or three thousand of them in
each available Sanctuary like you must
know that that is completely impractical
completely unrealistic in the real world
where would I put these horses
I hope you're not suggesting that the
British horse racing industry has in its
possession thousands of horses that they
wouldn't care for for the rest of their
lives we're talking about a four billion
pound industry here and I hope that they
have provisioned to care for these
horses for the duration of their life
Kevin they have provision for their
purpose aura that their primary purpose
you know these weren't bred to be pets
to be companions they're bred to have a
function there's a very clear
um there's a very clear steps along the
way for horses to be bred to be raised
to be then put into training to then
race and then there are very clear
structures for what happens after horses
retired but that structure is not cut
out for in sudden influx of fifty
thousand or sixty thousand or seventy
thousand thoroughbreds into that system
so and also you have to bear in mind all
of it if you as you seem to want to
um bring horse racing to an end you know
all the professionals all the horsemen
you know they're going to leave the
country they're going to go work
someplace else you know where are these
horses going to be housed you know the
vast majority of people that own
racehorses rely on their trainers to
house them you know most owners don't
have a bit of land that they can put
their horse in I want to uh just uh pick
up on a point that all are made she's
made it twice next also I'm fully aware
that last time we spoke I disclose the
fact that I am a horse rider a keen
horse rider and obviously I don't want
this to seem like it's a total gang up
on all they're here because I have a
horse in this race if you will but uh
please respond to the boy that all the
mates that a horse does die every other
day in horse racing and how that's
acceptable and what the industry's doing
about that
well across the whole year Rosanna
looking the figures are very clear 99.8
percent of runners in British race and
come back perfectly fine it sounds like
a big number to say one every other day
is actually one every two and a half
days if you break it down but that's
across almost 100 000 runners in it in a
year you know and that is that fatality
rate has gone down by 20 Sorry by by a
third in the last 20 years and there's
people dedicated to bringing that number
down to as low as they possibly can and
it's just so it's a point where it's a
point where it's making as well Rosanna
is that the way animal Rising talk about
racing and risk you know they imply that
a horse that isn't racing that is out in
the field is at no risk whatsoever and
like that that is completely inaccurate
because just as as an exercise I got in
touch with a bloodstock insurance
company and this week right because
there's there's no one that is better
equipped and better informed on risk
when regard to horses than bloodstack
insurers and they will actually quote
I'll quote you and your identical
mortality insurance rate and a yearling
that lives in a field night and day as
they will that same horse one year later
when they're in full training when
they're racing you know people whose
bread and butter is assessing risk
assessing the data they will tell you
that a horse is at just as much risk of
a catastrophic injury while turned out
in the field as they are in a
comparatively highly controlled highly
supervised environment in training and
racing you've made your point and I
think it's important to address that
point as well all that you've made some
interesting points as well this evening
which I do think will resonate with some
of our viewers as well uh thank you both
Kevin Ola for joining us in this debate
this weekend and uh wishing all those
involving up some Darby best of luck
given that there looks to be some
serious disruption there coming up here
on uncensored tonight it's been revealed
the legendary sitcom the office is
coming to Australia this time with a
woman playing Ricky gervais's iconic
character so does this mean Oz has gone
woke we're going to be debating that
next
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
coming up on the talk the cabinet office
is taking the covert inquiry to court in
the route over Boris Johnson's whatsapps
a Welsh labor MP loses the whip over
allegations of inappropriate sexual
behavior and the sussexes are reportedly
going to keep quiet from now on that's
all at nine o'clock
thank you
foreign
centered joined for the last part of the
show today by some familiar faces from
early on in the show contributor Paula
Rayne Adrian political journalist Ava
Santina and talk TV presenter Richard
Tice welcome to all of you let's have a
bit of fun shall we because it's been
quite heavy so far let's talk about the
office uh Ricky Gervais here
um was obviously famous David Brent now
the office has been franchised worldwide
uh this is the 14th version of the BBC
sitcom we know and love it's heading
over to Australia there he is the man
himself boy David Brent uh it is just
legendary isn't it but it's heading over
to Australia and he's going to be played
by a woman the character is going to be
called Hannah Howard and she's going to
be portrayed by comedian and Australian
Felicity award now the question being
posed here is Australia going woke I
mean but my utter response is Paula is
that women can be idiots in the office
too exactly can you believe that we've
got a sentence which it says that a
female actress has suddenly turned an
entire country woke yeah I mean I think
that says it all doesn't it it's a role
it's a character and of course anyone
can play that role in character and
she's clearly the best woman for the job
well will Australians go for it do you
think Ava I don't know I think they'd be
far well I'm more impressed with it
actually than the American version of
the office I think that was far more
offensive than a female lead could ever
be that was much more denigrating to the
comedic profession I would say but look
you know women are bosses it's going to
absolutely shock men to find out
to find out that women can actually be
quite funny and you know men are always
going on about how you should put the
best person forward from the job and you
know this is a commercial project and
they decided she's the best fit so there
we go oh Richard was it a diversity hire
for uh well actually no interesting I
suspect what they've done is they've
looked at some of the other franchises
elsewhere in the world that have taken
on men to try and recreate a funny
offers and many of them have actually
failed in a number of European countries
they haven't been funny the men have
blown it so the Australians have gone
semi-woke and they said well let's see
if someone else
well so what Richard is telling us then
is that we'll try the white male first
and if the white male doesn't work we'll
go for the theme
that is actually what happened they're
learning the lesson they're trying
something different let's hope she's
funny let's hope Australians you're
taking a risk right they're taking a big
risk but then the Australians love a
risk they do love it the biggest risk is
never take biggest risk is never taking
one that's what I say let's watch it
when it comes out and we'll make our
decision then moving on to other matters
but of course gender related because
everything is gender related now this is
the front cover of the magazine glamor
shortly set to come out front cover star
here Logan Brown that was Richard Tice
I'd like to say uh geforing in the
studio Logan Brown is identified as
trans male and is currently biologically
pregnant uh this cover of course talking
about you know the fact The Wonder of uh
being the proof of a pregnant male
um but obviously was born by Logic a
female hence can get pregnant so it's
you know depending on your stance in the
trans issue it is either confusing to
you offending to you or celebratory
which one is it for you Paula I mean
you're going to be shocked at my
response of course it's celebratory and
why shouldn't it be and can I just add
trans people did not just land to Earth
yesterday they have always so been here
so why is it only Now Magazine covers
because my my only objection to this you
know I'm fairly woke when it comes to
most matters is uh that corporations and
magazines seem to be exploiting this
movement for sales and for profit and
that is my only concern in all of this
really truly and as a woman who reads
magazines like this you know wouldn't
put me off buying Glam visit magazine
I'll probably pick it up because it's
interesting that oh that's something
different and that goes into the money
in their pockets but it does lead to a
narrative and a conversation it can be
toxic I think the problem is that a lot
of the press around this transgender
issue is is negative it's fear inducing
and and I don't know but I would hope
that what glamor magazine we're
attempting to do was to make it about a
feel-good positive story and this isn't
the first uh photo uh cover a cover of a
magazine with a transgender male who's
pregnant it's not the first time it's
happened
um and it will continue to happen and
quite frankly well done congratulations
to glamor for doing it over
congratulations well yeah I mean I think
far more toxic is you know the Decades
of women that we've seen on the front of
those magazine covers some which I found
very affecting when I was a young girl I
mean the amount of eating disorders that
were triggered from the you know the
size zero model on there telling us that
you know oh I eat pizza every single day
and I still look like this that was far
more harmful to a generation of women
and look the story itself is actually
really interesting if you delve into it
I mean he's talking about how he fought
for his masculinity like his whole life
and then becoming pregnant was such a
shock to him he came off the
testosterone because he was because he
was unwell and then became pregnant and
it was really affecting for him I think
it's a fascinating story it deserves the
cover Richard that's three women here
almost in unison give us the other bit
I'll tell you what the proof will be in
the pudding because it look that picture
sorry that front cover is a
contradiction in terms there's nothing
glamorous about that front cover and I
think they will find sales of that
Edition will plummet and it's the old
expression isn't it we saw it recently
with that German beer company budvisor
go woke go broke I think that's
catastrophic for theirselves but it's
their choice you know what sales plummet
and we have the Teletubbies or when we
have black
sales plan
was plucked there is a black Barbie
Richard
um those sales plummet but does that
mean that Mattel shouldn't continue for
example and toy toy companies
it's their choice I've just said the
biggest risk is never taking one I think
they're taking a risk with that image I
suspect that it won't sell very well and
they'll learn the lessons I mean it's
news it's fashion it's there's nothing
glamorous and attractive about that
picture your eyes Richard because that's
not the way you sway but for some people
maybe there is well let's let's wait and
see shall we let's come back on in a few
weeks time and see what the sales are
I'll tell you what I reckon I'm right no
would you be happy with that is that a
good thing
is I think I would say is it I don't
care it's their call it's their choice
if the sales are low if I'm right
they'll learn the lesson and look try it
panel we'll have to try it suck it and
see we'll find out next week thanks so
much for joining us in the studio Paula
Ava Richard we're gonna have to leave
that there today thanks to my panel
thanks to you for watching but before we
finish this stint for me on this show
this week and back over to Piers we've
had a lot of fun but we also want to
remind viewers of the ever-present
reality of the ongoing war in Ukraine
this heartbreaking image circulating
online today a grandfather sitting
beside the body of his nine-year-old
granddaughter who was killed by a
fragment of a Russian rocket it's
reported the man also lost his daughter
in the attack by the Russians of deeply
moving image one of just so many from
this war that reminds us what really is
important out there at the moment now we
say all that of course we do have fun on
the show Piers Morgan will be back in
next week talking about all matters
serious all matters fun at the same time
as well but is it from me very kind
appears Morgan to give me a seat for
another few days thanks to the viewers
for staying with us as well thanks for
the panel for that lovely Round of
Applause whatever you're up to make sure
it is uncensored good night
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign